non mesdames messieurs les ministres
cher collègue monsieur le premier
ministre
c'était au tour des pompiers
professionnels hier de manifester contre
le manque de respect du gouvernement
en grève depuis des mois parce qu'ils
assurent des missions qui ne sont plus
leur coeur de métier avec une forte
augmentation des incendies ils joignent
à leur revendication personnel des
hôpitaux eux mêmes débordés par
l'explosion de l'ensemble des services
hospitaliers notamment d urgence toutes
les professions au coeur des grandes
missions de l'état sont en crise
profonde
les policiers vous ont exprimé récemment
leur colère le suicide récent d'une
directrice d'école
la tentative de suicide une principale
montrent que l'éducation nationale n'est
pas épargné cette colère généralisée
exprime avant tout une crise de
l'autorité de l'état
vertus capitale pour une société ces
professions qui enseigne qui soigne qui
nous protège en ont assez des grands
discours qui ponctue une situation qui
ne cesse de se dégrader
assez de leurs conditions de travail
assez de la violence croissante dont ils
sont victimes
parce qu'il représente l'état lorsque
l'on touche à un pompier ou un
enseignant lorsque l'on insulte un
médecin c'est la république que l'on
défie cette année 1272 d'agressions de
pompiers ont déjà été recensé 312
pompiers ont été blessés nous avons le
sentiment que vous assister en
spectateur à une situation qui échappe à
pourtant c'est bien une des compositions
de l'état républicain qui se produit
sous nos yeux
les événements d'hier l'expriment
parfaitement l'état régalien n'assure
plus comme ils devraient sereinement ses
grandes missions de service public
comptez vous monsieur le premier
ministre répondre à la colère aux
angoisses des agents qui rendent un
service au public
qu'avez vous à dire aux pompiers aux
personnels soignants aux enseignants aux
policiers dans la dégradation de la
situation s'accélère pour vous répondre
la parole et tous